candidate Gene research this particular
Gene is related to depression this
particular Gene is related to memory
skills and so it makes you smarter
endless research on that loads and loads
and loads of papers published across all
the top journals millions of dollars of
research funding people raising their
entire careers writing their PHD
dissertations doing job talks getting
employed at top universities on the
basis of this candidate Gene research
and it was all nonsense
given your current academic background
at the moment
can you explain to people why you think
it is that behavioral genetics
has so much distaste distrust dislike
generally
there's a lot of different reasons I
think
the main reason is some kind of a
misconception about what it actually
means to say that behavioral traits are
related to genetics so I think when
people hear that especially when the
trait itself is controversial like you
can get into a whole debate about
intelligence or personality without even
mentioning genetics you know people
people get upset by just you know
mentioning those those traits but when
you see the link to genetics people make
lots of assumptions people think they
know your politics they think they know
like what you what you're trying to say
what you're trying to like slip under
the you know under people's under the
radar under people's notice
um and those assumptions are things like
well if it's related to genetics it must
be completely unchangeable
uh if it's unchangeable then we don't
need to do anything about our political
situation uh uh and we don't need to you
know help people out uh and people are
just stuck like a tram on a tram line
they can't they can't turn off or change
or in all that and uh uh if you're
interested in Behavior genetics you must
be using it to justify
our current political situation so I
think I think that like that's one of
the major assumptions
like immutability the the fear of
immutability
um uh and that's of course not what bay
of genetics says at all Behavior
genetics is about trying to understand
you know how things are right now not
necessarily how things might be if we
change things in the future
um uh or indeed if they may have been
different in in the past we have lots of
interesting studies of how like the
genetic contribution to things uh
differs across different times and
different places and different political
regimes even there's some interesting
research on communist regimes and how
that might have affected the uh uh the
the heritability of traits we can how so
yeah tell us about that well there's
some research uh in uh Estonia which
obviously used to be a communist uh
country and um uh so yeah this is a this
is a research using apologetic score
which uh your viewers may be familiar
with from uh hearing your interview with
Robert Pullman uh one of my one of my
colleagues uh here at King's College
London
um uh and so the idea is that you look
at the genetic contribution to various
traits and educational attainment being
the being the main one and before and
after communism in Estonia so that was
that was it's just this incredibly cool
paper that was done
um would be nice if it was replicated
and stuff but this is you know it's an
interesting it's an interesting uh you
need more communist regimes to come up
so in order for that to happen it's
going to be difficult you need a few you
need you certainly you need to do that
same study in lots of other like Warsaw
Pact countries uh which are now no
longer communism so the idea is that in
people who were born uh after uh
communism was gone genetics explains
more of the variation in uh people's
educational attainment for instance so
like and the idea is the broad
interpretation or one interpretation you
can draw from that is that a Freer
political system one that doesn't you
know oppress people in the same way the
communism does
um allows them to kind of uh reach their
genetic potential as one is one way you
might want to put it
um more effectively than one which kind
of where the environment really was kind
of suppressing people's ability to kind
of be who they who they really were so
that's that's one interesting uh uh
thing but that but you know in in just
saying that you can see how the
environment makes a difference to how
genetics operate uh and that's you know
research that's done by you know
Behavior geneticists who are not you
know criticizing polygenic scores
they're saying look we can use polygenic
scores to illustrate interesting things
about
our society and how Society changes and
so on so so I think it's a real
misconception to say that
um to see that uh you know genetics
means that we're immutable in in in in
some way I mean the classic thing people
talk about the the kind of
um the kind of Almost Boring cliched uh
thing that people talk about is glasses
right is is um uh uh eyesight is really
heritable so myopia short-sightedness
really really heritable
um uh runs and families all that sort of
stuff but you know we can we can cure it
instantly or effectively cure it
instantly by less like putting on a pair
of glasses at the right prescription so
things in the environment can uh um
completely alter the way that genetics
has has its effect now
it's a slight Copo to say that because
we don't have the environmental
equivalent of glasses for uh other
trades like personality like we don't
know the stuff that will massively
instantly change your personality and we
don't know the things that will
massively instantly change your
intelligence or your educational
attainment and all that
yet maybe we will at some point in the
future but we don't have that right now
um maybe it's a good thing that we don't
know ways to like massively alter
people's personalities using the
environment because of course that might
be used by uh somewhat nefarious uh
political regimes or Cults or whatever
else I mean Cults are already pretty
good at like controlling people's
behavior and so on and if they had ways
of changing people's personalities more
effectively then that might be rather
scary so
um uh yeah but that's but that's you
know one example that's very often used
um another one is height like height is
really heritable we know that tall
parents tend to have tall kids uh short
appearance tend to have short kids on
average so it goes and yet if you don't
feed a kid while they're growing up uh
they'll be stunted people in North Korea
are like six inches shorter than people
in or four inches whatever is shorter
than people in South Korea because of
all the malnutrition
no one's criticizing the fact that
behavioral genetics suggest that that's
the mechanism by which tall parents have
tall kids right we're not behavioral
genetics I guess but just heritability
generally right the height is heritable
what is it about other elements that
causes people a shoe size or eye color
what is it about that that causes it to
be such a different uh ballpark well
you've put your finger on the the thing
here which is the double standard which
is people are very very happy to talk
about
um uh you know genetic influences on
stuff like height or eye color and
things like that that don't have a
political valence but as soon as it you
know you use those exact same methods
and that's the important thing like you
use the same method studying twins
studying families studying molecular you
know DNA differences between people use
those exact same traits to study stuff
like intelligence personality whatever
and people flip out and that's
um uh I think a weird double standard
I mean what what would what would one of
what would one of them say in response
to that they would say well those traits
are a lot more complicated they're
they're socially influenced things like
educational attainment is influenced by
all sorts of stuff but the quality of
the school you went to
um uh the social economic situation that
you find yourself growing up in just to
jump in there didn't Plowman find that
when you uh equate for everything else
schools on their own have less than five
percent of an impact on someone's
educational outcomes that's the yeah
he's the ofsted ratings of schools to
show that yeah I think I think probably
in the UK that's probably true I think
in other countries that might that might
differ slightly like I think in
countries where the school's really
really dramatically differ uh uh we've
done a pretty good job of like
equalizing because of things like offset
inspections of you know fairly American
people that are listening offsted is a
external accreditation board that comes
in and make sure that the school is
doing everything right and the students
are getting the appropriate and we also
have a much more uh homogeneous teaching
uh curriculum right everybody across the
entire maybe UK but certainly England
has one set of exams at this age at this
age at this age unless you're in some
weird like international business
schooly type thing pretty much everybody
has the same stuff so you have this it
is a bit different and it is a bit
different in Scotland where I'm from
they have the it's got they have the
curriculum for excellence which I
believe is not that all excellent
um but but anyway yeah you're quite
right so so uh yeah what what Robert did
in that study was found that once you
control for the selection into uh into
schools so bring up private schools for
instance and uh so yeah there's two
different there's two different there's
there's the private school versus versus
State School one and there's the ofsted
ratings one and in both cases the
quality of the school uh doesn't make
that that much of a difference but I
think um
what someone might see in response to my
argument is that there's a lot of you
know I'm just using School quality as
one as one potential thing but like
there's a lot of other stuff that goes
into that
um uh something like intelligence
compared to something that goes into
height I'm not entirely sure about that
because there's loads of interesting
biological stuff going on with you know
uh nutritional intakes and uh all the
sort of stuff that happens when you're
when you're uh trying to understand
height and almost inevitably these
traits that we think are really
straightforward when we do more in-depth
genetic analysis of them even something
like eye color it becomes a much more
complex story as to exactly how it's
going on and there were some papers
recently on eye color that were
basically saying like the story is much
more complicated than me than we than we
thought
um
but that's also the case for things like
intelligence education personality all
that sort of stuff
um uh but but I think there's this kind
of allergy to even talking about stuff
like education as if it could be
um studied in a kind of genetic sense or
even among among some people like they
think that it can't even be studied in a
psychological sense as well like it's a
purely social thing like it's ridiculous
to try and quantify it and there's a lot
of you know opposition to
um quantification and and using
standardized tests and all that kind of
stuff
um uh in in these kind of contexts so
yeah I think people have this have this
strange double standard when it comes to
to that and also there's a double
standard in the opposite direction which
is they're very happy to
um when someone says you know uh this
particular you know intervention uh in
the environment whether it's teachers
doing something different or parents
doing something different or the
government doing something different you
know this had a big effect on people's
uh um on on on uh kids educational
attainment for instance using those same
kind of methods
um uh you could you could look at you
know genetic influences too like
polygenic scores using the same kinds of
statistics and the same kind of stuff
and yet people people are not happy to
take the same draw the same conclusions
there so there's double standards
everywhere people are just kind of uh uh
really they feel this real aversion to
uh genetic explanations so tell me about
where this is coming from because it
seems like
uh here's my here's the Bro science
explanation right that coming into
talking about behavioral genetics group
differences and individual differences
got lumped in together group differences
got used by people that have some pretty
nasty ideas about better and worse types
of individuals and that has caused
Downstream for behavioral genetics to
kind of be lumped in with
quasi-racists that's one reason another
reason is we live in a meritocracy and
in a meritocracy if you are your
successes and you own your failures
someone that is told that you have a
predisposition towards being more
successful ahead of arriving into the
world given that success and your
achievements in life are one of the
fundamental things that you take your
status and your well-being and your
sense of everything from that also feels
very unfair you know in a world that's
trying to give people a quality of
opportunity realizing that people start
like literally start the race at very
very varying levels is kind of a hard
thing to bring in here what do you want
us to do do you want us to try and
normalize for genetic predisposition
before people get to school that doesn't
seem very fair okay what happens if we
completely flatten the environment so
that everyone gets the same okay so what
you're saying then is that the only
difference is an outcome are going to be
exclusively genetic well God that
doesn't feel very fair either yeah yeah
absolutely and uh and the the funny
thing is that I think people
you know this is something which the
average person understands very very
well there's that paper that showed that
you know uh the people who get who are
the most accurate at predicting uh the
heritability of different traits or like
how heritable things are obesity height
intelligence whatever
um the people who are most accurate at
saying yeah genetics are probably
involved in that are mothers with more
than one child right so there's this
idea that if you've got one child then
you know that's interesting but if
you've got another one you can see all
right I'm not parenting this kid
particularly differently I'm not doing
anything massively different and yet
this child is totally different and to
be honest if you know anyone who if you
know brothers or sisters or you know
whatever siblings of any of any kind
like you know that they differ
dramatically in their personality and
it's probably not that they were like
expressly parented in a particularly
different way there are genetics that
influence that so we all we all realize
that some some kids are you know
starting school with slightly higher
aptitude for you know sitting down and
concentrating and some are some are not
but the thing is
the mistake is is to is to assume that
there's only one political outcome from
that there's only one political
interpretation of that because the kind
of more liberal interpretation of that
is well if people start off in different
things then you have to think in terms
of John Rawls like the um the veil of
ignorance this is what page Hardin talks
about in her book The Veil of ignorance
which is you know if you didn't know
what traits you were going to have uh
you could be any you could be entered
into the genetic Lottery as paid puts it
and uh and and start your life as one of
many people how should we set up the
world such that you're you know uh that
the world is as Fair as as as as it
possibly could be to whatever you might
be like
um and so that implies a lot of leveling
off that implies a lot of you know extra
resources for kids who are struggling uh
making sure that things are as equal as
possible making sure that opportunities
are are are given to kids who maybe
wouldn't otherwise get them so you could
draw a very you know Progressive liberal
conclusion from from that just as much
as you could draw the conclusion of oh
well we shouldn't bother helping people
because you know uh genetics is is
something an effect yeah it does seem
like a an incredibly illiberal way to
view the situation that that evidence
over there that could assist us in
helping people to get themselves to the
kind of life and the kind of world that
they want to have we we shouldn't know
about that well hang on whether you
decide to believe in it or not doesn't
mitigate the impact of it on those
people's lives yeah and I think I had a
great conversation with Paige and I
appreciated the fact that she engaged
with
given that she's very from the left an
incredibly difficult Circle to square
right it is very hard to work out how
you combine
left-leaning politics with a deep
understanding of behavioral genetics and
the impact that they seem to have on
people's outcomes in life
yeah totally and and uh that's
you know what one you know we must admit
as Behavior Analysis that one reason
that people have drawn the kind of more
right-leading conclusion in our and
unfear the writing conclusion is that
there are lots of figures in history who
who have drawn that conclusion right but
if you go right to the very start of
when people were kind of inventing
intelligence tests and and so on
um this was very much the idea so so uh
Godfrey Thompson who was this kind of
very well-known intelligence researcher
at the start of the 20th century at
University of Edinburgh there's a
um there's a a building named after him
in the University of Edinburgh education
School
where by the way they probably don't
teach that much about like IQ and and so
on anymore but it's somewhat ironic that
it's in instead of building the end
after him but fair enough
um uh he was of the opinion that and he
didn't do too much genetic stuff but um
he was of the opinion that you know
intelligence differences that that kids
have imply that we should spend exactly
the same on every single child so so
like
um you know no matter whether they're
struggling or doing really well every
single child should get the same amount
of resources from from from the state he
wanted things to be as equal as possible
and yet he was one of the pioneering
intelligence researchers and made major
contributions to our understanding of of
uh of exactly what intelligence is and
what the G factor is the general factor
of intelligence all this kind of stuff
um and and you know the the the the the
general you know uh influence that he
and other people around him at the time
had on the education system was that you
know there are all these people out
there who
um uh are you know would not otherwise
be noticed by the good schools because
of course at that point getting into a
good school meant knowing people
um your parents being rich and all that
sort of stuff and so we should try and
have an objective way of doing that and
that's why they influenced the butler
Education Act in the 1940s and and we
that's how we got the grammar school
system that we had in the UK for a long
time now
the grammar school system turned out to
be not particularly effective because
the people who went to grammar school
had a great time but the people who
didn't pass the 11 plus test which was
the the test that you the IQ test that
you did
um ended up in secondary moderns which
were very very poorly resourced
um and there's all these like hellish
stories of you know the latter half the
20th century that people went to
secondary moderns and had a horrible
time and I can totally understand these
crumbling buildings and all this kind of
stuff
um but but that was not the intention
like the intention of the psychologist
who set this up was a kind of was a kind
of noble one which was that you know we
were going to try and find
smart kids from poor backgrounds and
give them a you know a an academic
curriculum that was that is appropriate
to them not not give them more resources
or anything just give them an academic
curriculum that includes stuff that's
more appropriate to them and give an
academic curriculum to people who are
are you know are not as academically
inclined so um that was the original
intention
um you know subsequent to that there
came lots of people who did in fact
believe in you know eugenic theories and
and a lot of all the the stuff that we
know here IQ tests you know associated
with but you know the original IQ tests
were you know uh uh made for Noble
reasons the very very very first one
Alfred Binet in the 1910s uh was
invented to help kids who were
struggling in school uh you know kids
who maybe
um had particular you know what we would
now call you know special education
leads
um was invited to have an objective way
of diagnosing them and and giving them
extra attention and help so like the the
kind of um if you believe this stuff
therefore you must believe in like
predestination and immutability of
traits and you must be you know have
these these these right-wing uh views on
things it's just completely it's a
historical and it's uh and it doesn't
follow from the science am I writing
saying that the best evidence we have at
the moment is that IQ correlates 0.8 by
your 60s or something like that with
your parents about 80 is that right uh
well the Heritage ability so
there's this weird there's this weird uh
result where the heritability uh goes up
over time yes so like environment seems
to have more of an influence at the
start uh of your life and then uh it
gets less important in in measuring uh
uh you know the its impact on
intelligence and then yeah it goes up to
the heritability that is the percentage
of the the uh variance and the trade
that is associated with genetic
differences yeah it's it's 60 70 80 by
the time you do it and older folks you
know there's studies like
um the Vets are the Vietnam experienced
twin study where you've got all these
twins who are in they happen to be in
Vietnam that's not the most important uh
part of it but you've got all these
twins who uh were there and they did an
IQ test and uh and so on so um they've
got a younger IQ test and an older IQ
test and one that they did when they you
know when they went to Vietnam and they
were like 20 years old and one that they
did when they were later in life and you
can see that heritability uh increases
over over time yeah well I mean that
that's fascinating the fact that we have
so much of ourselves that is a part of
our parents is it's kind of something
that's beautiful but yeah I think the
the fact that plummand said uh it does
not predetermine but it does predispose
was was how he put it to me yeah Robert
has some of these phrases like like that
and like um it makes it uh it makes a
difference it matters but it doesn't
make a difference
is that the best way to express that I'm
not sure but there was a tweet that I
put out that I got a lot of pushback for
when I first had blowing on and it was a
quote from him from the episode he said
something along the lines of the single
most important thing that you can do for
your child's future happiness
educational outcomes and income is the
partner that you choose to have them
with
yeah it's I can see why people would be
upset by by that but like that's one of
the things that we know will have will
make a difference
um uh uh this other stuff in the
environment like interventions are we're
much less certain about
um you know just you know for instance
things like uh breastfeeding does that
does that improve people's intelligence
like that's a big big thing uh do they
kill nutrition yeah exactly um all sorts
of things like that like we just don't
know the studies are not that good on on
that whereas the studies are pretty
reliable in knowing that you know
genetics has an effect on on people's
outcomes that's a good question there
has been this big replication crisis
everywhere at the moment and it feels
like studies that were often used either
bro scientifically or really
scientifically are being thrown out how
much has behavioral genetics been axed
by this recent replication crisis well
um I think Behavior genetics I wrote
about this in my most recent book
science fictions which is about the
replication crisis exactly and um I I
think Behavior genetics was one of the
very first fields to be completely
smashed by the replication crisis in one
of its respects so in paper genetics
you've got lots of different you've got
lots of different types of research so
you've got research with twins you know
do uh the difference between you know
identical twins and fraternal twins and
like infering things from the from that
about how genetic particular traits are
that's one thing but then you've got the
molecular stuff and when I was a PhD
student so like 10 years ago
um all the way through
um that we had candidate Gene research
so it was like this particular Gene that
we have a theory about
um is related to depression for instance
or some things more complicated like
this Gene and if you get abused as a
child it's going to relate to depression
um this particular Gene is related to
memory skills and so it makes you
smarter if you if you if you have this
particular other variant of this Gene
um and endless research on that loads
and loads and loads of papers published
across all the top journals and many of
the non-top journals uh millions of
dollars of of research funding people in
basing their entire careers writing
their PHD dissertations you know doing
job talks getting employed at top
universities on the basis of this
candidate Gene research and it was all
asterisk not all but like 99 nonsense
it was all unreplicable
um almost all of them replica there's
like one example I can think of that uh
that didn't fail when people
thought wait a second should we try like
replicating these candidate Gene results
in big studies so not just like a
hundred people but like several thousand
people to see if this particular genetic
variant is linked to you know variation
in memory and so on and these were big
effects like there were there were
studies published in some of the top
journals that were like 20 of the
variation in people's memory abilities
are explained by this one this one uh
genetic variant
um looking back it seems ridiculous but
at the time that was very much you know
the the kind of standard study that you
would do
um it all felt a bit
um uh people tried to replicate it they
couldn't find that those genes were in
fact related to the uh the the disorders
and the traits that were uh related to
them
um and there was a massive replication
crisis and now we've moved on instead of
doing these candidate Gene studies we've
moved on to genome-wide Association
studies which instead of looking at like
one genetic variant you look at
literally hundreds of thousands of
genetic variants and it turns out that
for things that are complicated even
something like height but also you know
things like educational attainment and
so on
it's not that there's one gene that like
has a big effect it's that there's tens
of thousands of genes that each have
this little infinitesimal effect and all
builds up so you know you might have a
difference here and I might have a
difference here and and there's so many
many you know many many differences that
we have that make me slightly taller or
slightly shorter than you and or or
whatever it is
um and uh that's not how we think about
things and and in those genome-wide
Association studies we are finding like
replicable evidence now but like
genetics was was completely you know
Trashed by by the replication crisis um
you know in the early 2000s kind of
before we started even talking about the
replication crisis in Psychology this
was this was sort of happening and you
know the one that I can think of that
that hasn't you know failed entirely is
the Apple Eugene the Apple lipoprotein
uh e allele which is if you've got one
allele of this I think you've got like
uh uh substantially higher like twice
the risk of getting Alzheimer's disease
you've got two alleles of this is
something like 10 times the risk and
that comes out every every time for
Alzheimer's disease that's like the gene
that we know about it's related to
Alzheimer's disease yeah I've got one of
them I did my 23andMe I've got one of
them which is you know enjoy me while
you can because
but but you know
Behavior genetics has made substantial
reforms and we don't do that sort of
research anymore or mostly I mean you
see the odd paper coming up like I get
asked to review the odd candidate Gene
study and like the reviews can can just
be like
this will not replicate as well it's a
replica it's just it has to be about and
then
um so yeah as I say the stuff we've
moved on to which is the kind of world
of genome word association studies
polygenic scores all that kind of stuff
is much more reliable in its basic
associations however there's a whole
bunch of other things other like
concerns that are around that sort of
research so and I don't mean ethical
concerns and political concerns I mean
scientific concerns so like how much
does a sort of meeting I.E people having
kids with people who are like them uh uh
bias are uh estimates how much does
um uh uh not having diverse samples mean
that we're not learning enough about
actual you know Humanity in general so
like the vast majority of This research
has been done on people from a European
background uh you know white American
people or white people from Europe
basically
um and so you know and when you try and
use those polygenic scores they don't
predict as well when you look at people
from other backgrounds so we need to we
need to do a lot more research on on on
that to really understand you know how
these traits are made up and and
um yeah so there's all sorts of other
you know statistical and Technical and
all sorts of other concerns uh with that
but we are getting more basic you know
replications done whereas in the
candidate Gene research we just went way
ahead of of where the science actually
was and started saying well we found the
gene for intelligence of the gene for
memory the gene for depression all sort
of stuff and it was completely wrong and
I think we have to constantly remember
and have it at the back of our minds or
maybe even the front of our minds at all
times like
for decades maybe a decade we were going
completely on the wrong track and and
everyone was you know maybe not everyone
there were there were some people who
were saying well
for instance there are some people
saying didn't Ronald Fisher the
geneticist and statistician write a
paper in 1918 that said we should expect
really tiny effects of dreams and not
really big effects it's this research
kind of going against that some people
did point that out at the time but
nobody listened to them and we had a
whole field spending endless money
taxpayers money in many in many uh cases
just wasting it on statistically invalid
studies so we should we should always
remember that um and I think even areas
that are now a bit more rigorous like
Behavior genetics
um need to need to bear that in mind um
it's like the I don't know if this is a
historical but you know when uh when a
um Roman general came back and did a
Triumph in in Rome there was always like
a slave standing on on the back of the
Chariot saying like remember you will
die you know uh in in the rear I don't I
mean I think that might no I brought I
brought that up about Marcus Aurelius
the other day that as you walked through
the streets of Rome and everyone was
hailing him as this philosopher god king
and he was the this benevolent leader he
would have someone behind him the whole
time that would say you are only a man
right precisely so like I think we need
to constantly have that like there was
an replication crisis in your field like
just a few years ago you know so okay so
that's that's the genetic side of things
or the
um looking at the individual genes
itself yeah in terms of the behavioral
genetics environment versus uh uh Gene
side heritability side how robust has
that been in terms of replicating I
think the you know if you look back at
the twin twin stuff uh and the family
stuff uh so you know not using not
actually trying to go in and like
measure DNA differences but looking at
family uh differences that stuff is much
more robust uh much more rigorous it's
those studies are
relatively straightforward to do in the
sense that they were doing them you know
early in the 20th century and and so on
interesting potential fraud case with
with one of the very famous studies on
on intelligence and and and irritability
um Cyril Burt if anyone wants to look up
there's some interesting case there I'm
actually I'm actually halfway through
writing an article about this and
whether you know uh silver was a fraud
or or not because there are people that
have questions uh questioned that I
think probably he was a fraud but
um but anyway his results have been
confirmed by subsequent research which
is that yeah
if you ask you know to what extent are
uh traits like intelligence related to
genetic differences between people
you'll robustly get uh the answer and
then if you take a step back and just
you know forget the genetics and ask
things like you know is there a general
factor of intelligence like I I
are people who are good at one type of
intelligence test you know do they tend
to be good at every type of intelligence
test that's one of the most replicable
results in Psychology like you get that
every single time tests correlate
positively together and yet a lot of
people would be very upset to hear that
unfortunately isn't it it's quite quite
ironic that people are upset by one of
the most rigorous and replicate findings
but it but it's it's because it uh you
know it's this thing I mentioned right
at the start people assume that when you
say that you must mean all this other
stuff it's like no no when I say that
all I mean is that that people are good
at one type of test tend to tend to be
good at all the other ones
are there multiple types of
intelligences
well depends on what you mean so EQ is
EQ a thing well there's so there's a few
things to say
um
what you do in IQ test you will notice
that if you do an IQ test whatever you
will notice that there are lots of
different types of tests right so you'll
do a memory test a vocabulary test a
speed test
um uh all sorts of spatial rotation
tests shape rotators everyone was
talking about that on Twitter
um yeah word sales versus shape are you
a word seller or a shaper I think I
might be a I think I'm well I don't know
if I look at like people in the physics
department I definitely feel like it
works but but um but I I uh the
you know those types of tests could all
be described as like you know specific
skills right if you look back at Charles
Spearman in the 19 uh early 1900s 1910s
who was the first person to kind of talk
about general intelligence we we
remember him very much for talking about
general intelligence but he also talked
about specific skills too so
um the general factor of intelligence
explains like 40 to 50 of the variation
across all different tests like that's
one that's the rigorous finding that's
what comes out
um but there are specific skills too so
that and what that means is they can
vary independently of the general
intelligence I mean you know one silly
extreme example just to illustrate it
would be like if you sat down every
single day and like memorize the
dictionary every single day then your
vocabulary would you know your specific
skill of your vocabulary would improve
whereas that's not going to help your
um your you know uh shape rotation or or
whatever and in fact there's a whole
literature on on like working memory
training you know like those brain
training games that were quite a thing
for a while uh people did research on
that for a long time because they there
was this initial finding published in a
big Journal uh uh proceedings the
National Academy of Sciences that said
that if you do that stuff it improves
your your general ability
everyone was like oh my God you know
we've got to try and replicate this and
it didn't replicate it felt a bit when
people tried to do studies they had
better controls and all that sort of
stuff
um but that was the idea you know that
that training up one task can transfer
to other ones that that seems to at
least for the case working memory that
seems not to be the case
um
but yeah so that's one thing to say is
that there are all these different
specific skills they tend to correlate
together but they don't correlate
together at like one so they are
different to some to some degree so if
you mean other multiple intelligencies
in that respect there are specific
skills that's the most obvious one then
there's is there this thing called
multiple intelligences theory that was
made up by Howard Gardner at Harvard
University
and when I say made up I actually you
know use that word advisory because he
didn't have any data he just decided
that there were these different types of
intelligence you know
um it's not it's not the same as
variable auditory kinesthetic learning
which is another thing which you know
schools love but it's that kind of thing
that there are these multiple different
types of intelligence arithmetic
arithmetical intelligence and uh and so
on and over the years he's added new
intelligences so he's decided that there
are new ones there's existential
intelligence now
um interpersonal interpersonal
intelligence
um naturalistic intelligence which is
about like how much people know about
plants in the garden and stuff and he's
decided that that's an intelligence no
those are skills those are real things
that we that we that we care about it's
in it it's cool to meet someone who
knows the difference between plants you
know when you're out in the woods or
whatever that's that's great but is that
what we would call an intelligence in
the same way that we would talk about
like you know verbal and spatial
abilities probably not
um uh does it mean that there's no such
thing as the general factor of
intelligence no because there's actually
no empirical content to the to the
multiple intelligences Theory whatsoever
it's just one guy's opinion
um which is remarkable like Harvard
psychologist had a massive impact on the
world and the way they think about how
the human mind works having done no
research it's not you're saying you're
saying that there's still potential for
my academic career yeah you don't need
to do any research just come up with an
idea that people like and they will
spread it around every school I'm
brilliant at doing that yeah well
exactly exactly so that's a good thing
then you mentioned uh emotional
intelligence EQ eats IQ for breakfast
that's there's like another which is
like another thing and my understanding
of that is a few years ago there was a
meta-analysis done on all the research
predicting job performance from uh EQ IQ
and personality right and what they
found was if you just look at EQ on its
own it predicts job performance people
who have higher emotional intelligence
do better at work right so there you go
that correlation is there if you just
look at the bivariate correlation
between those two things
totally totally uh uh robust there
however if you put intelligence and
personality like the Big Five
personality factors you had Christian
Jarrett on the show recently talking
about that sort of thing
um into the same equation then EQ no
longer has an effect and that's in
predicting in predicting uh job outcomes
and that's because EQ is just a
redescription of stuff that we already
knew about right so so it's just a
redescription of being
you know caring about what people's uh
feelings and emotions are right so
that's one that's one part of it and
some of that comes across in some
personality uh factors and being smart
enough to kind of operate in your mind
okay that person must be thinking this
way you know I can I can kind of if I
say this to them it's going to have this
effect like it takes quite a smart
person to be able to kind of I mean the
slightly derogatory way of putting it
would be like manipulate people in in in
that way
um so in predicting job performance it's
just a redescription so I can't remember
which way around it is there's the like
people talk about the jingle and jangle
fallacy right and one of them is the
Jingle fallacy is
describing the same thing with a
different name and therefore thinking
it's something different and then a
Django fallacy is calling different
things the same name and thinking that
they must be the same maybe it's the
opposite way around I can't remember uh
which way which is jingle which is
jungle but psychology psychologists do
an awful lot of that like redescribing
things with a new name and and thinking
it's something different one example is
grit right so
um there was this big book in like 20.
Angela Duckworth yes Angela with book
um
16 something like that that came out
that was that was great it's in every
single School in the country everyone
loves it like the power of persistence
and passion and all that sort of stuff
if you look at the studies
like it's literally you know it's
correlated to 0.9 on a scale of minus
one to one it's correlated like 0.9
conscientiousness with conscientiousness
it's just the same thing I didn't even
didn't even know that and I picture
there you go and and you know there's
met analyzes that have come out saying
that it really is just a redescription
so it's not wrong it's not that great is
a lot of nonsense and it's also not that
emotional intelligence is a lot of
nonsense it's just like it's a jungle
it's just a new way of talking about
something that we already knew about and
so you know the contribution there is
I'm not clear what the contribution is
apart from like you know maybe
popularizing old stuff but that's what I
would say I would say that given the way
that pop psych works at the moment that
create a branding problem a catchy
branding problem is 90 of the battle I
know that um growth and fixed mindsets
came under the ACT actually why don't we
do this give give me some of your
favorite
eviscerated psychological Concepts from
the replication crisis what is what's
dying bleeding out on The Cutting Room
floor well I mean the classic one I mean
I'm very happy to talk about growth
mindsets we can come to that but the
classic one that kind of was there that
kicked off the replication crisis in
many ways was priming like social
priming which is that there are all
these things in the environment uh words
phrases uh ideas and that when you see
them it changes the whole way that you
act so the classic study which I
remember reading as an undergrad and I
was being I was taught it in lectures
and I remember read the study I was like
wow this is amazing it was in the
textbook incredible
people you set people down in a lab with
a computer and they're doing like some
task where they have to like tell
whether a sentence is a real sentence or
or a word is a real word like there's
words and known words you know
um and some of the words that come up in
one of the conditions you know for half
the participants are to do with old age
so they say things like Zimmer frame or
um fragile or frail or something yeah
exactly fragile frail one of the words
that I remember that was used in study
was Florida because apparently people in
the US associate that with all people
fantastic and it seems about 10 years
but that's what they that's what they
said
um and then what they found was that the
and you know for the other half of the
participants it was just random words
that didn't have any particular theme
and for you know the the half that saw
the words with old people
they walked more slowly out of the lab
right so they they when they were
leaving the lab there were like people
measuring with stopwatches and they want
more slowly that was apparently finding
I remember reading that in social
psychology literature and going wow
that's incredible that's amazing to
believe that
um and there was a whole range of
studies like this
um showing people the American flag
makes them much more likely to vote
Republican at the next election even
years later you show them the American
flag once and they'll Republican later
people you know serious scientists
publish that in scientific journals
serious science journalists wrote about
that in you know whatever you know
whatever magazines that they were
writing about science in and didn't
think a sense of impossible
um uh uh another classic example which I
don't think has ever been I don't think
anyone's ever attempted is replicate it
but it was um
though you go into a room and there's a
box in the middle of the room like a
cardboard box and half the participants
uh sit in the box and they do like a
creativity task like how many uses of a
for a brick can you think of like that
sort of creativity task and half the
participants sit just next to the box
right and what they found was that the
presidents who were sitting next to the
Box had a higher creativity score and
they thought it was because they had the
idea in their head activated of thinking
outside the box right I mean literally
this is how uh absurd you know some of
the social psychology
come on that was published in
psychological science one of the top
journals of the field in 2012 I think
um and so that idea of priming
was our social priming uh behavioral
priming has really Fallen by the wayside
linguistic priming
uh I think it's pretty solid so like if
I say an active sentence then you're
more likely to say an active sentence
back rather than a passive sentence you
know that sort of that sort of thing
like that slightly more boring stuff is
is totally it's totally real but the
kind of Darren Brown thing where you
like just show someone one phrase and it
totally changes their their behavior and
I think Darren Brown actually like
picked up on a lot of this stuff and put
it into his magic act you know
um I don't think he was doing priming
either I think he was doing magic tricks
which is totally fine but like he
claimed that he was doing you know this
kind of putting an idea in your head
sort of thing that stuff is completely
Fallen by the wayside I think that's
that's but I you know you don't see new
studies on that kind of thing anymore uh
very much anymore because there were
some very prominent attempts to
replicate that including the one with
the people walking more slowly at the
lab they actually got um instead of
people with stopwatches who by the way
knew what the hypothesis of the
experiment was
um they put laser like like infrared uh
things on the corridor like 100 meters
yeah exactly so they would break them as
they walked through and there was no
difference uh when you when you do it
objectively like that isn't it there's
no difference
um in the people who'd seen the old
words versus not growth and fixed
mindset yes well there's another one
which I think the story of growth and
takes mindset is a bit different in that
it's not complete bollocks in the sense
that the the priming stuff was but it
was massively overplayed and I think
um
the over the the real um you know if you
look at the original discussions of
growth mindset early 2000s uh maybe late
90s early 2000s
this was this is going to change your
life change the way you talk to your
partner change the way you your kids do
at school change the way you think about
your life it's gonna be massive it's
gonna have an enormous fact they
published a paper in science so like
what's meant to be the second best
journal in the world saying that growth
mindset could solve the uh Israel
Palestine peace process like I'm not
kidding that's a paper that exists in
published in science and it's all like
very borderline statistic results
physical results and that sort of stuff
I actually
having no remember that I feel like I
should go back and do a little um do a
little debunking of that because I've
not seen uh anyone talk about that but
um
you know and and over time what you now
find is that the people who are doing
research on growth mindset claim things
like
growth mindset is a cheap intervention
that can have a a small to modest effect
on kids uh educational attainment that
is if you go into classrooms you teach
kids
um working hard is good you can change
the way that you uh you know you can
change your level of ability you can
change your skills you know uh then that
that does seem to have a a small effect
on kids Behavior as as I think I would
predict it would right it like that
makes sense if you tell kids you're
completely stuck there's nothing you can
do then you know I can totally imagine
that many of them will uh uh uh um you
know we'll we'll take that to heart and
and uh and it'll at least have a small
effect on there seem to be slightly
bigger effects on kids who are from very
low income backgrounds for instance so
that's that makes that make sense too so
like now the now the claims there used
to be these absolutely dramatic claims
about how it would change your life now
it's like this should be part of the
toolkit in education and that's good and
that's because
people have come along and
done meta-analyzes of all the research
and found that the effects are really
really small on average like the effects
are are not earth-shattering effects
they're like just about there sort of
thing
um and and that's much better but I
haven't seen anyone say
oh sorry we misled the entire world for
decades about about you know how much of
an effect these things will have I feel
like
this kind of thing might be being used
in a few schools now if they've talked
about it on the level all the way
through but it's now it's in every
school in in the country because the
claims being made for it were
revolutionary when in fact the data just
didn't back up at all I had David Robson
on to talk about the expectation effect
have you seen that uh I mean I'm aware
of the the the sort of effect I don't
know is there is a book or yes yeah yeah
so he wrote a book science writer very
good really really good and I would
highly recommend you go and check it out
uh and so he's talking about basically
the placebo effect but across multiple
different sorts of domains right the
expectation that you have about your
outcomes can very heavily influence the
outcomes my two favorite studies from
that one of them was talking about
um
gluten intolerance has 10x from 3 to 30
over the last 20 years so they brought
people into a a food Hall and they put
them under study settings some people
didn't did not have self-reported gluten
intolerances I told everyone that they
were going to give them a meal which had
gluten in had no gluten in right people
were breaking out in hives running to
the toilet with diarrhea that had
inflammation all of this stuff the other
one was a study about VO2 max tests it
turns out that um a particular type of
genetic variation allows you to blow off
CO2 and up regulate oxygen more
efficiently people were brought in they
were split randomly into two groups that
were mixed with do and do not have the
genetic variant one group has told you
do one group has told you don't you
should do really well you should do
really badly surprise surprise the group
that was told that they should do badly
did worse overall however
what they found was that people in the
group that were told they would do worse
but did have the correct uh genetic
variant to blow off CO2 didn't do as
well as the people that didn't have the
genetic variation but were told that
they should and David's synopsis for
this was your expectations are more
powerful than your genes now he's doing
it as a little bit of a tongue-in-cheek
sort of play my point being
you have the opportunity with the
expectation effect to create a s a
placebo
sense of what may be the outcome is that
justified in jazzing up some sort of
effect and is there maybe an argument to
be made that the more sexy that you make
it the more outlandish that you make it
sounding it does end up becoming a
self-fulfilling prophecy you do end up
getting people who believe in ego
depletion I'm sure that you've seen this
people that believe that willpower is a
limited resource have limited willpower
people that don't believe that that's
the case seem not to I'm not sure how
replicable that is well I think yeah I
think there's been some controversy over
that replication but yeah no I get I get
the the the the idea is there a
justification for people jazzing up any
kind of psychological uh tool that you
may be able to use because by doing that
you increase the expectation effect
which does genuinely increase the effect
the only issue is that it's not
happening on the mechanism that it's
claimed on yeah I mean well it's not
just psychological stuff I mean if you
look at like the whole term of bedside
manner that doctors use it you know
doctors can have a big effect on how
their patients do by just being nice to
them or acting in a way that acting in a
way that um that's not like you know
really harsh or or accusatory or
whatever
um I think any doctor will tell you that
that's the case however I think we
really like the the most important thing
as scientists that we that we have no
when you're doing an intervention at
school and you're a teacher I think
jazzing it up whatever you know carry on
if it helps that's completely fine but
as scientists our number one thing is to
try and get to the truth and uh and you
know we need to complete like control as
rigorously as possible for these kind of
effects and that's really hard in a
behavioral context it's really hard to
make the control group feel like they're
doing something similar to the the
um the kind of active treatment group
it's really really difficult
um they're maybe not having exactly the
same kind of intervention they're if if
it's one of those video game studies I
mentioned before there may be you know
there were loads of studies published
where the control group was just people
who didn't do anything uh versus people
who are playing the video game and what
you want is someone to be playing like a
different video game which you don't
think has the active ingredient of like
the brain training or whatever it is
um but that's hard and
um it's so hard that when you look
across studies you find that tons and
tons and tons of studies even you know
randomized medical trials don't really
have very good controls
um whether it's like a placebo pill or
whether it's just you know
um uh treatment as usual or whatever
um people don't put as much effort as
they shoot into these controls and I
think I think um you're absolutely right
that there are these there are these big
expectation effects you've got it you've
got to try your best to roll them out
because it's a big source of bias in
these in these kind of studies I'm just
reading a a meta-analysis on Homeopathy
right now that claims Homeopathy helps
people's ADHD I'm just writing a a Blog
about it which is a very interesting
case of a meta-analysis by the way which
does everything right it's
pre-registered it had a bias check it
had a publication bias check it did like
it was all everything was all done you
know uh uh by the book and yeah
obviously it's bollocks anyway because
it's Homeopathy so so it so it like
you can follow all the rules and still
and still have and and still uh not have
um a realistic result but one of those
rules that people need to follow a lot
more and when people look at the quality
of Trials medical trials over the years
they do find that
um the quality has been increasing
somewhat you know since the you know the
latter half of the 20th century people
are getting better at doing controls
people are getting better at blinding
people are getting better at doing
randomized uh studies now so like if you
look at a randomized control trial now
on average it will be better than a
randomized controlled trial from like
you know the 1980s or even 1990s a
little bit on average that's that's what
that's what the best data uh shows as
far as I'm aware but um but yeah these
expectation effects still come up in
you know in loads of different and loads
of different trials so I've just
realized my question was should we not
be telling the public something which
can benefit them by using the
expectation effect to fill in gaps in
the magnitude of something that's maybe
quite small what you're saying is that
science needs to protect itself from
this by using unbelievably quarantine
quarantined uh
um controls making sure that this
doesn't impact because the expectation
effect can be such a big yeah I mean
this in that case it works in both
directions you can influence publicly
what people think all right what the
other one that I saw which I haven't
spoken to anybody about yet and you're
the guy
what happened with the recent SSRI and
depression stuff because that
demonstrates I think quite nicely how
important it is to get this right
because you're potentially going to
commit
tens of millions hundreds of millions of
people perhaps over several decades to a
particular course of treatment that may
be based on something that isn't legit
have you looked at this yeah um it's
funny because it relates back to the
Homeopathy thing I just mentioned
because in that Homeopathy met analysis
they say well Luke we know that there
can't be any actual you know molecules
of the substance left in the homeopathic
remedy because it's been diluted so many
times that there aren't any molecules of
of whatever you know uh uh active
ingredient left but the randomized
control trials show that there is
overall an effect and therefore we don't
need to know the mechanism
we just know it has an effect right and
and I think that they're wrong about
that but it was interesting that they
said that because under most
circumstances I would actually
that argument sounds quite good to me
just not in the case of Homeopathy which
obviously is is is is literally
impossible for it to be having an effect
and given the laws of physics as we as
we as we know them but the SSRI thing is
interesting because they're making a
similar argument there they're saying so
this paper that came out recently from
um I think it was University College
London
um said when we look at you know so the
theory underlying SSRI antidepressants
is that they they allow you know for
differences in the amount of Serotonin
that people have in their brains and
that might affect their uh their um
their their depression levels they mean
that there's more serotonin just going
around in there and it was always a bit
of a vague Theory and I think most
researchers would say that the kind of
chemical imbalance Theory uh is it's a
very very
high level like it's a thing that that
maybe doctors will say to their patients
but it's not actually that justified by
the science and indeed this study kind
of confirmed that which is that there's
no obvious differences in the amount of
serotonin in the brain of people who are
depressed versus people who aren't
um now uh uh if you think back to the
Homeopathy thing then it's like well
okay the mechanism isn't there maybe the
mechanism that we think uh uh uh you
know has an effect isn't there
but if you look at you know ssris
they're not like Homeopathy in that like
they have big side effects people who
have ssris have not a huge range of
different side effects so there is
something active going on uh uh in in in
there and it could be that they're
having an effect even if not via the
serotonin so if you look at the studies
on antidepressants
um my friend saloni tatani did a great
uh series on um you know the website our
world and data oh yes I do yes I do yeah
yeah you've probably like everyone's
seen the graphs from that website and
stuff but if you they publish a whole
lot more interesting stuff she did a
whole series on uh antidepressants and
the research and her overall conclusion
was
and this is broadly my conclusion as
well when I looked at literature is yes
the effects are exaggerated in the
literature so
um if you look at the way that
antidepressant studies are published
um there was actually a really
terrifying study done on the on
antidepressants uh I think this applies
to almost all areas of science which is
they took
uh registered trial so when you do a
medical trial you've got to register
with the government right that's just a
kind of you know legally you have to do
otherwise there's no way you'll ever get
it published so there's Registries and
they have like all the trials that have
ever been done on on them and in this
particular selection of trials they
found that it was about 50 50. so about
half of the trials in the antidepressant
didn't work and half the trials it did
but by the time it got to the studies
that actually got published in papers
almost all of the negative studies just
no one ever sent them for publication uh
but almost all of the positive studies
people did send for publication
then if you look at those uh the the the
the few negative studies that actually
got published they kind of shifted the
outcome a little bit they said well we
were going to measure things on this
depression measure but actually uh we
didn't find a result on that so we'll
just we'll talk about a different
depression measure which we did find a
result on so this like you know dredging
through the data to find any old thing
then if you look even closer you find
that even some of the negative ones were
kind of written up in a slightly spin
sort of way like a positive sort of way
saying like well this is very promising
and also when actually it was just a
null trial and so the literature that we
see at the end of the kind of this kind
of process and it's almost like a like a
little laundering process of of the
literature it doesn't bear much relation
to the studies that actually were done
which is really scary and I think that
happens across all areas they actually
find in that same paper that it applies
to therapy trials as well not just
antidepressant trials so I mean that
is like a really really terrifying uh
Discovery having said that I still think
that if you adjust for that kind of
thing the publication bias and so on it
is the case that antidepressants do seem
to have a very you know like a like a
small effect on on people's levels of of
depression I don't think the mechanism
matters in that case I think
um uh even if it's not to do with
serotonin they seem to be doing
something and the randomized control
trials do do seem to show that but then
there's like massive interpretational
differences in
um in how you look at the numbers so uh
Irvin Kirsch the famous critic of um
antidepressants published a book called
the emperor's new drugs I think it's
called about antidepressants and he said
an effect size of 0.2 is the average
that you get out of uh studies of
antidepressants so like 0.2 standard
deviation difference in the depression
score what a tiny pathetic effect you've
got to give up these drugs that don't
have another effect that's that's not
going to you know work at all
you look at the the you know most recent
meta-analyzes that are published that
account for things like I was talking
about the publication bias and they say
effect size of 0.2 effective medical
treatment this is really good you you
know even though it's not a massive
effect this is still going to have a
bigger impact across the population and
all sort of stuff so people can look at
exactly the same uh data and draw
massively different interpretations my
interpretation is
we've got to do a bit better on this
we've like
we've got to do proper research and
really understand uh this and and get
better at treating depression both from
the therapy angle and the the drug angle
um but at the moment it does look like
on average
for for each person who uses them like
one type of of antidepressant will will
uh have some kind of mild effect at
least on their under depression now I
think one of the big things that hampers
depression research is that we're not
very good at defining what depression
actually is
um so there's loads of research on
whether
you know we've already talked about
there's this thing called intelligence
right
um and intelligence doesn't exist in the
sense that there's not like a thing we
can measure with a ruler in the brain or
anything like that that is intelligence
we infer the existence of intelligence
from the fact that there are all these
different tests that you give people and
they correlate positively together and
there's this thing that comes out this
latent variable that comes out and it's
called intelligence
that explains you know half the
variation in the test and all sort of
stuff and so the question is you know is
there something called depression that's
the same that's the same thing that we
can infer from all the symptoms
insomnia low mood
just crying sometimes for no reason uh
you know all the different things that
come with with depression
is there this thing called depression
and the argument from quite a lot of uh
people uh Ico freed is one who's a a a
someone that I've um uh known for a long
time a researcher who's done really good
research on this his idea his his idea
is that there isn't necessarily this
thing called depression and what we
should be focusing on is the symptoms we
should be focusing on this kind of
network of symptoms which sometimes bump
into each other and cause each other so
like the insomnia causes low mood and
the low mood causes you to be angry at
your spouse and that causes you to and
and so there's all this kind of like
Network and you can try this very
statistical approaches you can try to
understand this kind of network of
effects and that's a different way of
looking at things than saying that there
is this thing called depression that
causes all the symptoms
um uh this latent variable which we'll
never be able to measure this that cause
all symptoms I'm kind of undecided on
this debate I think
um
uh it seems quite a quite a strong thing
to say that there's no such thing as
depression because
like a lot of people seem to have very
similar symptoms over over time and
um the General Medical approach is to
try and treat the underlying cause
rather than symptoms and and so this
would be quite a uh this would be quite
a departure from that but I think the
the the
um there's a lot of mileage in this kind
of research of like examining the
symptoms rather than saying
um you know there's this one thing which
we we have to try and treat so
um you know that might be one of the
reasons why the trials on
antidepressants are are kind of all over
the place is that they all measure
depression slightly differently people
experience depression slightly
differently uh people are at different
phases of depression and and the
symptoms might be different and if One
symptom causes another then in different
ways in different people so it becomes
like a moving Target rather than you
know I don't know if you were doing a
drug of if you're doing a a test of like
do you have the covert virus in your
system which is you know yes there's
difficulties in in some ways of
measuring that but like it's a much more
objective thing than you know are you
depressed I mean there's many different
ways you can you can answer that
question that seems very much like a
behavioral geneticist's answer I spoke
to plumen about a year ago and he was
telling me he says he has a uh
predisposition for being fat
um and he said it was such a great
example and it really helped to identify
how this collection of genes contributes
to the outcomes that we get in life so
he said that whenever he walked past a
bakery if he smells fresh bread he will
be going in and he will be buying it and
he will be eating most of it but there
are many ways to get fat you may be fat
because you have an aversion to exercise
you may be fat because you have down
regulated ghrelin release so that the
hormone that tells your stomach that
it's empty that signals to you to eat
maybe that's
upregulated or some you know there's a
million different ways that you could do
that or for you to be fit maybe you
don't sleep so much so you're always up
early and because you're up early it
means that you go and exercise because
you've got nothing else to do right
there are tons and tons and tons of
different things and the same thing goes
for what you're talking about here what
you talk about when you're referring to
depression is a particular milieu of a
bunch of different things that people
seem to link together where do they come
from is everyone's depression the same
you're never going to actually get to
experience somebody else's brain so you
use these words to describe but we all
know how uh in culturally influenced a
lot of the things that we consider are
right we use the language that other
people have done it's precisely why
juries aren't allowed to or they're told
not to watch the news while they're
doing for precisely that reason to not
try and influence their opinion so it
does make a a good bit of sense I also
think is it what's it called the
Richmond scale of depression and it's
not to 61 or something like that or the
Richard scale that's a lot there's the
back depression inventory and there's a
there's a whole like
yes and I'm pretty sure that no matter
what the mechanism is that ssris could
be working on it seems like they get to
move someone about a point on one of the
scales that I seem to remember reading
about yeah and you go well a point isn't
nothing but it's a big difference if
it's the one between taking your life
and staying alive sure so saying that
there is no use for them that seems like
baby and bathwater being thrown out but
saying that it's this effect but then
also going well serotonin does seem to
impact people's subjective sense of
well-being and how they actually so if
it like it it's a it's a mess it's a
mess and a huge amount of that mess
comes from low quality research like low
quality studies low quality uh
antidepressant trials low quality
research on Depression more generally
people not thinking about alternate
explanations of the the the data and
kind of getting stuck in in particular
paths and I think this is a broad
problem across all uh uh research but
yeah you're completely right that um uh
this is this this becomes like a real
great Thicket of of uh of of convocation
however I do I feel uncomfortable going
too far down in that particular line
because like for many years
uh anti-psychiatry the anti-psychiatry
movement has made like these similar
arguments and I I feel like an aversion
to say well maybe they were kind of
right in some in some in some respects
because you know they are they are uh I
mean it's about to say they are insane I
mean the the that maybe that's not an
insult to them because they don't think
there's such a thing but um you know I I
live
um uh I I work um at the the maudsley
hospital in uh in um in uh in London
which is a psychiatric hospital our
campus is like behind the the the
psychiatric hospital and you know every
so often there's scientologists out
there uh uh protesting because they have
this big anti-psychiatry thing so
they're really worried about what's the
problem with psychiatry
well L Ron Hubbard didn't like it
um I think possibly because he saw a
psychiatrist and the psychiatrist said
you need help and so he was and so he
was uh now Downstream from that The
Echoes of L Ron Hubbard's bad
interaction with a psychiatrist are
still that's my understanding that's my
understanding and I think and I think uh
you know they are trained from day one
that like Psychiatry is the evil thing
and psychiatrists are out to
um to to manipulate Us control us
imagine that yeah it's manipulate and
control us but
um but um uh yeah particularly
psychiatrists it's very very strange but
um they were particular there were there
were uh campaigning about electoral
shock treatment which is another like
interesting thing which like my
understanding is if you talk
psychiatrists
um that for very very severe cases of
depression where people are like
literally catatonic and can't move from
from depression electroshock uh
electroconvulsive therapy different
color
um does does help it can kind of jolt
people out of these kind of catastonic
states
however
um we don't really know that much about
it and certainly the long-term effects
it's it's on it's unclear I saw a
meta-analysis that looked a bit um a bit
shaky in terms of its statistics I'm
going to write something on this uh soon
there's a scientologists have like
inspired me to like uh look into this
but um
what I don't think it is is like a a
terrifying cabal of psychiatrists who
are trying to control the world I think
it's I think it's like
it's been observed anecdotally at least
in many cases that this helps and so and
so uh uh people people use it but yeah
you know there was a whole you know
through the 1970s 80s this whole
movement of there's no such thing as
schizophrenia it's just a bad adaptation
to the societal conditions that people
uh get get uh get put in no no there's
this thing called schizophrenia it's
really bad like psychosis at least
there's this thing and it's really
really bad and people lose uh complete
control of their grip on reality
um and and and that's a really serious
thing and it's not to do with Society
it's something you know very that's gone
very very wrong in their brains and and
that's another thing that we don't know
how to treat that well I mean We've Got
Drugs antipsychotics that can can kind
of hold it hold it back but it's
difficult to know how to sort of prevent
or predict it kind of like the broken
clock is right twice a day scenario it
seems like if you have a replication
crisis and a lot of studies in
previously held models are up for The
Chopping Block there will be some people
in the past that decided to point at
that and that that ends up making them
seem like Cassandra's right very
effective ones so given given the fact
that you've got
this Thicket as you put it which is a
complete mess even for people who like
you can read scientific papers who like
you understand how effect size is and P
hacking and all of this stuff can be
done and coming out the back of two
years where everybody had to be a closet
epidemiologist virologist and understand
you've got uh the media perverse
incentives click bait you've got
academic issues with regards to the only
stuff that gets published is the stuff
that is set all of this stuff all put
together first off it's not a surprise
that people are losing faith in the
powers that be in the ones that they
should have done
the bigger question I think is how
people can be effectively skeptical
without losing faith in everything and
becoming confused and nihilistic and
easy to manipulate I've just written uh
the start of a book proposal on exactly
that question of like how do you
question the consensus without like
losing your mind and becoming a
conspiracy theorist and uh
I I I think this is a really difficult
task because the the incentives are so
strong once you see that you know the
scientific establishment is really
screwed up uh on something like the
replication crisis or you know you
mentioned you know during the pandemic
there were all those cases of studies
that came out that were fraudulent uh
papers having people retracted from the
Lancet because they were they were based
on entirely fraudulent data like there
was a study on hydroxychloroquine that
had to be retracted and the lands that
were like
well from now on we're gonna this
literally this is what happened they
said from now on we're going to make
sure that at least one of the reviewers
uh of the paper one of the peer
reviewers has expertise in the topic uh
uh that they're reviewing it's like well
you didn't do that before so so you know
I can I like I understand why some
people are like holy [ __ ]
but I think part of it is that we need
to raise our standards in general like
um we need to first of all we need to
have some standards rather than just
accepting stuff that someone on our side
says uh which is a massive Temptation
for all of us there's someone we trust
they said something so we're like oh
yeah I'm sure that's I'm sure that's
true
um and that's kind of my argument in in
the previous book in science fiction is
that like if you raise your standards
then you won't become a homeopath or a
conspiracy theorist or whatever because
because the the standards that you have
are you know we'll we'll just kind of
you know all that stuff will get chucked
out as well it's just that you'll also
Chuck out lots of really crap you know
mainstream science too
um uh so I think there's probably like a
good checklist that can be written for
like how you should read papers and I I
kind of sketch one of them out in the in
the previous book but I think I'm going
to do a book length treatment of that
like what to look at when you're reading
the scientific evidence
um but even then like you can't be an
expert in every single area and it takes
it takes uh expertise in in each hair so
I think what we can do is encourage like
a free and open and and to be honest as
aggressive as possible debate on on on
scientific research so there's like
there's organizations out there like the
science Media Center for instance and I
would encourage anyone if they see like
a controversial paper in the news
um take a look at the science Media
Center website because what they do is
they ask a whole bunch of scientists
um who are unaffiliated with the study
itself what they think about it and so
you'll get you know six or seven
responses and sometimes they say this
study seems perfectly good but regularly
they say
this has been way over hyped there's a
major problem with this study you know
what would be an amazing website would
be Rotten Tomatoes but for psychological
science studies yeah well there's
already a website called um called Pub
Pier so um like publication peer or
whatever Pub peer which which tries to
do that exact thing and so they've got a
little bot that goes through Twitter and
finds like threads that people write
about papers and post them under a link
to that paper on on the website so if
you again another thing which people
might be interested in doing is if you
find a paper that looks dodgy in some
respects put it into Pub here and see if
there's any discussion and that's that's
pretty much what you're talking about
the only problem is there's so many
papers out there uh and you know nobody
has the time to to kind of look into
them all and there's probably not
discussion on every single paper that
you want there to be discussion on but
another thing they do on Pub here is
look for fraud so they'll say
do you think that the microscope picture
in figure three looks like it's been
photoshopped and it turns out that in
many cases it has uh there's this
incredible
um she calls herself scientific
Integrity Consultants called Elizabeth
Bick who goes through thousands of
biological papers and finds that
scientists you know they don't just
manipulate data when they do fraud but
they manipulate the pictures as well
whether it's like blocks or microscope
images all that sort of stuff so many of
them have been like duplicated retouched
recolored cropped all that sort of stuff
to show the results in a much better
light and that's scientific fraud but it
happens in thousands of papers every
year and peer reviewers look at it and
go nope looks fine to me and it gets
passed on and so this whole Community
has to come out and and re-review the
papers
and I think encouraging that sort of
thing exactly as you say websites that
do this kind of thing that that collect
together reviews of papers collecting
other people's opinions another thing
scientific journals can do and some of
them are doing this now including some
of the top ones like nature they're
publishing the peer reviews alongside
the paper so you can see what people
thought of it when they first saw it and
it's and and in some cases including a
case I saw recently of a a big you know
this genetics paper that claimed to like
revolutionize genetics when in fact I
would say it didn't at all like you can
see that the reviewer said no no no
there's a big problem here the control
condition doesn't work
and the editor just was like well better
publish this anyway and and just like
completely ignored what the reviewer
said so so but but we can see that
that's obvious now we wouldn't have been
able to see that back back before they
published reviews science was just done
in a complete Black Box
so this movement towards open science
that is publishing the peer reviews
online publishing the data set online so
anyone can go in and dig into it and
have a look
um making sure that the paper is open
access so anyone even if they don't work
at a university and they don't want to
pay for the paper can can click it and
read it
um making sure that the materials are
online so other scientists can come
along and replicate it in exactly the
same way a big problem is that
scientists read each other's papers and
they don't even know where to begin to
to to start replicating uh the paper
because they they're like oh uh there's
there's actually there's no description
here of what they did in this particular
condition so I'm gonna have to spend
months emailing back and forth with the
scientist like what is the point of
scientific papers if they don't actually
describe
um what what you what the you know what
was done in the experiment well it turns
out in in many many cases they don't so
um
yeah there's this there's this movement
of open science I think one sort of like
Rule people could have in their heads is
like if a paper looks like it's open and
transparent they've published their data
online everything's open and clear
they've registered their plan like
before they touch the data they've
actually like registered the plan of
what they're going to do with it so they
don't like [ __ ] about with it when they
when they when they get the data and
like oh
well I'm sure that participant wasn't
paying attention or that person let's
cut out everyone above 50. even though
that wasn't planned but let's call
everyone who's above 50 because I think
probably older people have a different
reaction to this drug uh this sort of
thing happens all the time and you can
kind of justify to yourself like yeah
yeah it is the case that older people
have a different reaction to this drug
so let's just cut them out all together
oh Lord behold we found a significant
result let's send that off for
publication like and it wasn't that case
it wasn't that wasn't the case before
they did this so having a clear plan and
sticking to it uh posting your data
online probably most frauds are not
going to post their data online because
they're scared that there'll be some
like obvious thing in the data like
number seven comes up too often or
something like like and they and they
like so it doesn't seem like a real data
set
um those are kind of things that you can
look for but I also think seeking out
other scientists opinions uh and and
something like the science Media Center
is really useful for that but also just
like looking on Twitter and seeing what
people have said about paper like okay
you'll get lots of uninformed takes on
the paper as well but you know seeing
what people said you don't necessarily
have to agree with it or have to take it
as gospel but you know seeing that okay
actually
maybe tweets one to five of the thread
are kind of like are garbage but tweet
seven actually does illustrate that
there's a problem in table three of this
paper so I better just just you know
adjust my certainty about it somewhat so
like there's that that sort of thing and
you know that's what I'm doing when I'm
like writing about
low quality papers I'll read the paper
and have my own critique of it but I'll
also see what other people have said
about it because the whole point of
having a scientific Community is that we
all like criticize each other all the
time and one of the big problems is that
we've got to the point where it can be
very socially awkward to criticize each
other
um some Fields this is much better than
others in Psychology
um as much as I enjoy going to like
psychology lectures and so on everyone
is generally quite nice to each other
and they're like oh that's a great paper
well done they start off like my friend
Chris shabri pointed this out recently
like often the person who's cheering a a
a a seminar will start the question an
answer session by saying
that was a brilliant talk thank you so
much for that
that sets the wrong tone because the
tone you actually want is okay thanks
for giving us the talk
does anyone want to critique that you
know and in economics I've only done
this once in economics I went to
economics uh seminar thing and I was
told I was doing a talk
but I wasn't talking about my own stuff
I was to talk I was given someone else
this data set who would be that was
presented earlier that day and I was
told to just like check it critique it
and do my own like mini talk at the end
of his talk that was critiquing it
that's the sort of thing we want now
economic seminars can get a bit like
natural regressive like that sort of
thing and that's you know can can
distract from the actual content which
is what we want but that sort of level
of like constant skepticism constant
argument is what science is all about
and I think we lose that if people are
basically too nice and too trusting of
each other and those are like being nice
and being trusting
they're good things that we want to
encourage
but maybe not so much in science
Stuart Richie ladies and gentlemen if
people want to find out the stuff that
you do online where should they go I'm
on Stuart J Ritchie on Twitter I'm also
stuartritchie.substack.com uh for all my
uh longer ratings and my book is uh
science fictions came out a couple years
ago amazing Stuart I appreciate you
thank you thanks so much what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
face
[Music]